welcome to this video playing the sage
the sage from the netherlands is this a
name nah come on give me a name or not
I'm pretty pretty fresh account or not
that money Vinnie games played haven't
played in one video before let's see ok
I get the line the zurich line played
against against me we are playing one of
the main continuations here
now I can play with efore with e3 this
is some not quite clear what the most
promising way to players yeah that's
interesting my black is trying to to get
control over d5 now the bishop on c3
it's not that great at the moment so I
need to do something about it in fact 98
is helping me quite a bit in this aspect
because I'm just winning the exchange I
still need to activate my bishop en mi
90 m sorry let's see how do i activate
it yeah I probably want to try to take
on d5 and at some point to get them to
get the rooks active so I'm playing this
to play cd5 next activating on the C
file
classy takes d5 before okay wait if I
take 94 I've g3i I want to let's cover
that for the moment now maybe here I
haven't to get getactivity v7s attacked
and it's really a some time until he is
threatening summer tech here like 95 and
a second age 3 this is taking quite a
long time so is some giving up b7 okay
yeah I will take it I mean definitely i
have c 6 now for the look this is very
important yeah whoops is 6 or what is
best I want to trade queens of the
sleigh Quincy 6 also possible or queen
c7 Quincy 7 is actually really almost
trading at you can go to you sick son
yeah it does not matter relief this is
also good Queen the eight Queens is 72
trade Queens
or jump or that one attending rook c8
check
whoopsie aid
check black resigns yeah it was very
handy this happy should be formed of all
of a sudden yeah his general idea is
correct yeah you want to reroute this
night from six but of course the move
Ottawa some was bad luck is okay in this
position I mean he just has to attend to
the bishop before I do you like with a
five or queen d7 first White's ideas so
to do something like that and then play
on the Queen start like it's okay though
it's probably better played this a
little bit here there's castles it's
probably better to do this now this is
this is in fact right I was forgetting
to play this this move first and only
then castle or away Eddie for something
like that yeah in the game here black is
ok but ok this blunders just the
exchange and he had my only thing that I
want to do is I want to see that the C
file is opening up energy for to prevent
that and now the sea fog is opening up
so that my my extra exchange really can
play a role I can play on the C file and
then with enough pieces traded it's
relatively easy within an endgame or
simplified Miller game yeah okay thanks
for watching